اسواق كل عملات الرقميه منذ نشاتها كانت
متقلبه وعدوها الرئيسي هو انعدام ثقه
الناس امرنا ان يحدث الان بالطبع فقاعه
ماليه وان طال عمدها وهكذا يراها
المعارضون لكن ثمت معارضين مختلفين هذه
المره نشاطاء البيئه فما هي العلاقه بين
العمله الالكترونيه والاحتباس الحراري من
يرغب في امتلاك البيتكوين من يرغبون في
ذلك ليسوا مضطرين لشراءها يمكنهم قاعدينها
افتراضيه طبعا كل ما يجب فعله هو حاسوب
لحلي بشائر الرياضيه ومعقده وكامكافاه
تصرف عملات رقميه مقابل ذلك في البدايه
كانت العمليه اقل تعقيدا وبطبع اقل
استهلاكا للطاقه واما الان
والمنافسات تستلزم وتسخير عددا كبيرا من
الاجهزه المتطوره لحل المساله اولا
بالتالي طاقه كهربائيه اكثر
للتوضيح فقط من اجل تعدين 36 وحده بتكوين
الثانويه تستهلك اجهزه الكمبيوتر كميه
كبيره معادله لاستهلاك دول مثل هولندا
وباكستان سنويا
لتغيير اجهزه الكمبيوتر في كل مره بحجه
ضروره عدم تاخر التكنولوجيا اكيد وهذا ما
يزيد من حجمه النفايات الالكترونيه الخطره
وارتباط العملات الرقميه بالاحتباس
الحراري تسبب في انخفاض قيمتها مدى هذا
واضحا عندما اعلنت شركه تسلا تعليقه قبول
كملتي سدادا قبل ان تستخدم الطاقه النظيفه
في تعديل نصف العملات الرقميه على الاقل